Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg returns to
Capitol Hill in a few hours for another
marathon day of testimony he was
questioned by nearly half the Senate
yesterday
about his company's failure to protect
user data
Zuckerberg repeatedly apologized for
making mistakes
well Wall Street seemed to approve of
his testimony Facebook stock gained
four-and-a-half percent its biggest
one-day increase in two years this
morning House members get their chance
to question Zuckerberg Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill where the Energy and
Commerce Committee will hold that
hearing Nancy good morning good morning
it's damage control day too
and Zuckerberg is going before a House
committee today where things can be a
little more freewheeling than they tend
to be in the Senate at the same time
he's now a seasoned pro having testified
for four and a half hours yesterday and
taking questions from 41 senators the 33
year old CEO now knows what he's up
against
lawmakers who say a sorry isn't enough
how was today's apology different stop
apologizing and let's make the change
we should have handled a lot of things
here differently Zuckerberg admitted
Facebook should not have waited some 2
and a half years to inform up to 87
million users that their data was
harvested by a third-party app posing as
a personality quiz the data was then
sold to Cambridge analytic a political
consulting firm tied to the Trump
campaign who at Facebook had this
information and did they not have a
discussion about whether or not the
users should be informed we clearly view
it as a mistake that we didn't inform
people and we did that based on false
information that we thought that the
case was closed and that the data had
been deleted Zuckerberg insisted Tuesday
that Facebook can police itself and that
its mission has evolved it's not enough
to just build tools we need to make sure
that they're used for good it's as
clitter the same as what you do it
overlaps with a portion don't you have a
monopoly
all right certainly doesn't feel like
that to me okay
several senators argued that Facebook's
privacy controls are confusing on
purpose your User Agreement sucks the
purpose that User Agreement is to cover
Facebook's rear end it's not to inform
your users about their rights would you
be comfortable sharing with us the name
of the hotel you stayed in last night no
that may be what this is all about your
right to privacy the limits of your
right to privacy everyone should have
control over how their information is
used every day you people come to our
services to choose to share photos or
send messages and every single time they
choose to share something there
they have a control right there about
who they want to share it with
Zuckerberg is sure to get asked again
today about the Russia investigation
after this revelation Tuesday have you
were anyone at Facebook been interviewed
by the special counsels office yes
Zuckerberg said he personally has not
been interviewed but that other
executives have he even indicated that
the company may have been served a
subpoena by the special counsels office
he said he wasn't sure but said Facebook
John is cooperating with the probe a
photographer captured Mark Zuckerberg
notes for yesterday's hearing and what
have we learn from what was captured
well we learned John that he was
prepared to talk about a whole host of
issues that didn't really come up in the
hearing things like the lack of
diversity in Silicon Valley but what's
getting a lot of attention this morning
is the fact that he was also ready to
take a couple of swipes at a competitor
you'll recall that in the weeks
following the Cambridge analytic a
scandal Apple CEO Tim Cook criticized
Facebook's handling of this situation
and said he wouldn't be in the situation
because they have a different business
model at Apple well under the headline
Tim Cook on biz model there were five
bullet points including quote lots of
stories about apps misusing Apple data
never seen Apple notify people and
important you hold everyone to the same
standard a little bit of deflection
there thanks very much Nancy we'll see
if he brings that up today
beware of those long-range lenses